[Music]
back-to-school season means scouting
fashion inspiration if you're looking to
add some royal style to your look for
the new year check out these modern
princesses to get you started if this is
your first time here don't forget to hit
that subscribe button do you like making
crafts check out our friends over at
crafty hackers they'll show you how to
turn your everyday objects into awesome
things now let's find out what with
Disney Princesses look like as teens
[Music]
Rapunzel this drawing of a long-legged
Princess Rapunzel was created by Bev
Johnson Bev studied at the Rhode Island
School of Design she wanted to develop
casual versions of her favorite Disney
Princesses the illustration perfectly
captures Rapunzel's excited and curious
energy who are loving her relaxed and
girly style in a super cute dress and
comfy sweater her iconic hair hangs over
her shoulder in a thick braid adorned
with flowers we can't help but notice
that Rapunzel has definitely had a trim
in this depiction who was the choice to
shorten her hair merely to make the
character more realistic maybe the
artist is celebrating the freedom
Rapunzel finds from her controlling
captor either way this reimagining of
her puzzle is adorable snow white's this
version of Snow White is goals every
part of her look is making us drool
platform boots a double-slit skirt and a
tank top bring this princess to the
bleeding edge of fashion her full sleeve
tattoo pays homage to the princesses
roots her dark lip look and gorgeous
sunglasses
Linda grown-up and sultry tone and check
out those earrings but we're loving the
intrigue the fun kicks a haircut and
bold brows are on points Victoria Evans
has taken Snow White from the 1930s to
2018 flawlessly we are loving this edgy
look we need to talk about Tiana in this
sweetly ruffled Sun dress can you handle
how adorable this illustration is this
light sunny yellow is the perfect color
the playful ruffles soften a serious and
hardworking character and that kitschy
frog purse we're eating it up in The
Princess and the Frog Tiana is reserved
and goal driven we love her work ethic
and dedication to her goal
it's incredible to see this determined
character portrayed by Bev Johnson with
so much fun energy even her hair is
laid-back and simple her natural hair
beauty shines in this low-maintenance
but high style look Cinderella then
every piece of princess inspired artists
sweet Italian artist Emanuel V's visions
are a bit spicier his version of
Cinderella is a tattooed and pierced
pinup his work showcases the rebellious
and robust spirit in every princess
he's created a Cinderella who isn't
afraid to be herself who are loving the
green hair and the victory rolls a
septum ring leans and edgy but still
trendy tone this fierce rendering is a
beautiful contrast to the princess's
humble roots the artist has thoughtfully
included tattoos that honor her loyal
friends this girl won't be scrubbing
anyone's floors she's too busy being a
girl boss Jasmine Princess Jasmine is a
strong woman who thinks for herself she
refused to marry a prince and demanded
to marry for love we love her fierce
independence and adventurous spirit
artists and children's book illustrator
Anusha Syed has brought this independent
girl to the 21st century in her
illustration jasmine is a stylish travel
blogger Anushka sees jasmine with
accessories that express who she is her
friend Raja is honored with a killer
tiger print bag her harem pants are a
stylish nod to her Middle Eastern
heritage we loved the little detail of
the genie lamp on her cute tee jasmine
is still a cat lover the artist imagines
she has five at home mamako she's in
charge of every single day of my life
Merida who doesn't love wild girl Merida
her strong will and bravery made her a
fan favorite artist Bev Donson imagines
this fiery princess as a cute casual and
feisty team Merida's look is adorable
the hunter green of her button-down
complements her red mane we're loving
the denim shorts and stocking combo
paired with personal accessories this
look is effortless how cute is that belt
buckle or those tights we can barely
stand it we love that the artist didn't
try to tame Merida's wild hair she's
still the free spirit we all know and
love the only thing missing is a cute
arrow necklace Milan Milan is one of the
most essential Disney Princesses she
dared to obey her father and her culture
to save her country the real-life Mulan
was just as inspirational and became a
general Victoria Evans vision of the
courageous warrior captures her
willingness to ditch societal norms
artist Victoria Evans portrays Mulan as
healthy fit and sporty and perfectly
coordinated athletic wear her low
maintenance haircut and killer abs
demonstrate that Mulan lets nothing
distract her from her goals we love this
look for such a physically strong
character this illustration shows that
nothing looks as good as being true to
yourself though who doesn't love sweet
Belle this bookish daydreamer was
willing to sacrifice herself for her
father and even saw the good and beast
Val is a sincere and studious girl with
the heart of gold
this illustration of the bookworm beauty
by bev johnson is too cute for words her
simple ponytail and giant glasses
capture her humility her look is cozy
with an oversized cuddly sweater her
blue pen aphorism nod to her 16th
century wardrobe this comfy outfit makes
it easy to picture Belle curled up by a
fire with a good book for loving a cute
bow in her relaxed ponytail that was
adorable style would be the envy of any
bookworm
erielle fans of The Little Mermaid know
princes Ariel as the headstrong and less
an obedient daughter of King Triton half
of the film seems to be Ariel getting in
hot water not a saint art imagines the
ginger mermaid as a hip-hop loving gamer
girl
Ariel rocks diddums shorts in this
rendering her purple clam shells have
been replaced with a bot crop top Ariel
is comfortable being herself and chowing
down on pizza while she kicks back
playing video games were loving her wild
hair held back by a bulls cap Pocahontas
this progressive princess is stunning in
the portrayal of her as a college
student the artist imagines Pocahontas
uses her love of communication and
diplomacy as she studies linguistics the
silhouette of her dress is a throwback
to the original look of the character
her blue eyeshadow is a 100% modern
addition the cute compass tattoo on her
calf showcases her pioneering spirit and
of adventure Anusha sigh at imagine that
Pocahontas is still a thrill seeker
spending her free time hiking up
mountains and kayaking down Rapids we
love the faux raccoon tell on her bag
and the shell necklace the artist nails
the character in her adorable look we
hope you love these modern-day
princesses before you go don't forget to
check out our friends over at crafty
hackers if you love Disney you
absolutely have to check out their
videos on Disney inspired DIYs so you
can create some of these outfits at home
go give them a like for all their hard
work see you next time
[Music]
[Music]